on the day Federal Reserve Chairman Ben
Bernanke was named Time magazine's
Person of the Year Vermont senator
Bernie Sanders reaffirmed his opposition
to the Chairman serving a second term
this is a half hour okay how weird it go
why don't we thank all of you and there
are a lot of you for coming thanks and
I'm pleased to be joined this afternoon
by William black is over there in the
corner who is an associate professor of
economics law at the University of
missouri-kansas city and has been active
for years and years on government
financial issues and Robert Boris our
show is the co-director of the campaign
for america's future one of the larger
progressive grassroots organizations in
America as all of you know tomorrow
morning the Senate Banking Committee
will be deciding whether ben bernanke
deserves another four years as chairman
of the Fed let me be very clear I don't
believe that he deserves another four
years as you know I placed the hold on
his nomination and I'm going to do
everything that I can to see that he is
not reappointed last year in the
presidential election the American
people voted for change in our national
priorities and for a new direction in
our economy after eight long years of
trickle-down economics that benefited
millionaires and billionaires while
leaving the middle class further and
further behind Americans demanded a
change that said that government would
start paying attention to the needs of
ordinary Americans and not just the
wealthy and Wall Street what the
American people did not bargain for was
another four years for one of the key
architects of the bush economy and I
think sometimes this is forgotten
because we pay attention to Chairman
Bernanke as a member of the federal
chairman of the Fed we forget that in
the year two thousand and six
Chairman Bernanke headed the Council of
Economic Advisers for president bush in
other words he was a key architect of
the bush economy and I believe that when
the people voted for change in 2008 to
move our economy in a different
direction they did not vote to have one
of the key architects of the bush
economy being reappointed as chairman of
the Fed let's also be very clear that
perhaps more and I want to say i have no
personal animus toward Ben Bernanke he
seems like a nice man he's certainly an
intelligent man he's a hard-working man
but that's not the issue the issue is
has he been successful in doing what his
job requires him to do perhaps more than
any other person in the entire world
Chairman Bernanke was in a position to
diagnose and correct the impending
financial disaster that was taking place
right in front of them one of the key
functions as you all know of the Fed is
to oversee the safety and soundness of
our financial system he was chairman of
the Fed and all around him wild
speculation illegal behavior gambling
casino type activities were taking place
where was Ben Bernanke the chairman of
the Fed when all this was happening now
some of you may have noticed rather
ironically I think Time magazine has
just named Ben Bernanke as person of the
year I would also note that 10 years ago
Time magazine referred to Alan Greenspan
Robert Rubin and larry summers as quote
the committee to save the world but what
I find most interesting is that time
magazine acknowledges in their awarding
mr. Bernanke this title exactly what
everybody knows to be true this is what
they say quote Bernanke was as clueless
as Greenspan about the coming storm he
dismissed warnings of a housing bubble
he insisted that he
economic fundamentals remain strong in
March 2007 he assured Congress that
quote the problems in the subprime
market seems likely to be contained end
quote the day before the global crisis
erupted with a run on a French bank the
Fed was still saying its primary concern
was inflation quote Bernanke had no idea
what was going on a foreign central
banker tells Time magazine when he took
over the Fed in 2006 after an uneventful
eight-month White House 10th leading
Bush's Council of Economic Advisers
Bernanke said his top priority would be
continuing Alan Greenspan's policies
quote Ben and I have never had a serious
disagreement mr. Greenspan says does
anybody serious believe seriously
believe that with a record like that
that this should be a man reappointed as
chairman of the Fed now the Fed has four
key responsibilities this comes from
their own website not from me number one
it's a conduct monetary policy in a way
that leads to maximum employment and
stable prices to to maintain the safety
and soundness of financial institutions
3 to contain systemic risk and financial
markets and forth to protect consumers
against deceptive and unfair financial
products those are the main activities
that the Fed is obliged to undertake to
my mind and I think to the mind of any
fair-minded person mr. Bernanke as
chairman of the Fed has failed in every
one of these fourth areas since Bernanke
took over as Fed as you all know the
unemployment rate has more than doubled
today seventeen percent of our people
are either unemployed or underemployed
not since the Great Depression as the
financial system it is unsafe unsound
and unstable as it has been during
Bernanke's tenure more than 140 banks
have failed since he became chairman 140
banks under Bernanke's watched the value
of risky derivatives held at our
nation's top commercial banks grew from
110
two more than 290 trillion Bernanke
failed to prevent banks from issuing
deceptive and unfair financial products
to consumers under his leadership
mortgage lenders were allowed to issue
predatory loans they knew consumers
could not afford to repay just the
direct cause of the financial crisis
we're in right now this risky practice
was allowed to continue even though the
FBI warned in 2004 of an epidemic in
mortgage fraud that had the potential to
become the next S&L crisis according to
the FBI after the financial crisis hit
Bernanke's response was to provide
trillions of dollars in zero interest
loans to the largest financial
institutions in the world I will never
forget being a member of the Budget
Committee asking Chairman Bernanke can
you tell me can you tell the American
people which financial institutions
receive receive trillions of dollars in
zero interest loans that was not a hard
question and mr. Bernanke said no I
won't tell you and that day we issued
introduced legislation that would in
fact make him reveal that and bring
transparency to the Fed the reason that
the Congress against my vote approved
seven hundred billion dollars to bail
out Wall Street because we had
institutions that were too big to fail
they would cause systemic risk of the
entire economy if they failed today
under Bernanke's watch three out of four
of the largest financial institutions
are bigger today than they were before
the collapse now that makes sent may
make sense to somebody it does not make
sense to me now mr. Bernanke after the
bailout could have done a number of
things the suggest that he was standing
up for working Americans and the middle
class he could have insisted that bailed
out banks and usury asst practice of
charging interest rates of thirty
percent or higher on credit cards he
could have required bailed out banks the
stop making risky bets in derivatives he
could have required bailed out banks to
modify mortgages
so that homeowners could afford to stay
in their homes he could have required
too big to fail banks to become smaller
as is going on in the UK and as many
economists are calling for he could have
instituted a major investigation to
determine how we got into this disaster
in the first place he did none of those
things so let me just conclude I have no
personal animus to Ben Bernanke but I
think all of the objective evidence
suggests that he has not done a good job
in this enormously important position
and I am requesting that President Obama
give us a new nominee a nominee who will
understand that is his or her main
interest has got to be to protect the
middle class and working families of
this country and not just a big money on
Wall Street let me introduce a professor
Bill Black built motor club I've been
asked to be very brief to give you more
time for questions so I'm going to
concentrate only on the regulatory side
first thing that you need to know is
that the Fed was unique it had authority
under an act called who eva during this
entire time period to regulate and
prevent the subprime lending by
otherwise unregulated entities these are
the mortgage bankers primarily that made
eighty percent of the non prime loans
the Fed under Greenspan and under
Bernanke refused to use that authority
and it refused to use that authority
even though the FBI warned publicly in
congressional testimony beginning in
September 2004 that there was a quote
epidemic unquote of mortgage fraud
developing and predicted it would
produce a financial crisis unless it was
prevented and Bernanke's colleague on
the Fed Ned Gramlich personally warned
that there was a housing bubble of em
immense proportions developing and that
there were extraordinary problems in
subprime lending and that the examiners
needed to be sent in and this is what
the senator was just talking about there
was never a disagreement on substance
between Greenspan and Bernanke they were
the twins on these issues they refused
to send in the examiners they refuse to
use their authority under the statute go
forward in time it is I think no secret
that the Chamber of Commerce is not
exactly a friend of the Obama
administration and the president has
just said that he wasn't elected to
represent fat cat bankers well Ben
Bernanke is the person who delivered for
the fat cat bankers in a form of the ABA
American Bankers Association and for the
chamber of commerce because what they
desperately wanted and what Ben Bernanke
signaled approval for picking up even
their talking points in the language
used was to gut the accounting rules
this year and so now banks don't have to
recognize losses so what do they do they
report that they're highly profitable
and that produces immense executive
bonuses we have lied at the behest of
entities that are a completely repugnant
to the administration supposedly and yet
the administration seeks to reappoint
Ben Bernanke who has brought this
disaster that's going to produce the
next disaster as well another name that
probably are fact it's probably obscure
but shouldn't be Chairman Bernanke has
just appointed Patrick Parkinson to be
the head of all supervision and
examination all regulation at the
Federal Reserve well who is this man
this is the man who led the charge to
destroy Brooks Lee borns attempt
to regulate credit default swaps which
are what blew up AIG and are going to
cause perhaps 150 billion dollars in
losses to the American taxpayers and why
did he do it because he said you can't
have fraud in financial markets that are
sophisticated what is exactly what
Greenspan said that he did as Mia culpa
on is I thought reputation would have
prevented any of these problems right
that is an absurd proposition the FBI
again had publicly warned whose expert
in fraud the FBI or the economist's at
the Fed pretty clearly the FBI and they
have chosen to put in place someone who
has been wrong on every step of the way
in regulation and explicitly follows
Alan Greenspan there is no fraud there
is no reason to regulate I will also be
briefed my name is Robert Faurisson I'm
the co-director the campaign for
america's future which is a center of
progressive ideas and organizing focused
on kitchen table issues we are one of 17
groups ranging across the political
spectrum that have issued a letter to
the Senate committee urging it not to
vote Bernanke's nomination out to the
floor of the Senate without first
investigating both his record and his
current views demanding an investigation
of the Federal Reserve and a probe of
Bernanke's views strikes us after the
worst financial calamity since the Great
Depression as simply common sense I'm
not going to repeat the bill of
particulars that senator sander sanders
and professor black issued about how
Bernanke got it wrong going into the
calamity as head of the Fed but to
suffice it to say that in every specific
area that were critical to the crisis he
got it wrong and the Fed contributed to
the crisis awarding Ben Bernanke man of
the year as time
zena's done is something like awarding
an arsonist and celebrating an arsonist
for helping to put out the fire that
they had just put a match to the Federal
Reserve has a mandate of both price
stability and maximum employment we've
just had the largest spike of
unemployment since World War two under
Ben Bernanke's ages it is worth
understanding the views that contributed
to that calamity and whether professor
Bernanke has learned something from them
Alan Greenspan who was Bernanke's mentor
in many ways came to the committee and
said that he got it wrong that his
worldview was skewed and that he had
been mistaken it is worth the Senate
committee asking Bernanke did you get it
wrong why do you think you've got it
wrong what have you learned from this
calamity how have your views changed it
is not enough to say as bernanke said in
the desultory a couple hour hearing that
the Senate Banking Committee held it is
not enough to say that well a lot of
regulators got it wrong we're not
appointing a lot of regulators to be the
head of the Fed and is not sufficient to
say that a lot of the crisis was not
under his purview he was the head of the
Federal Reserve and we expect the
Federal Reserve to be in charge of the
safety and soundness of the banking
system now once the banking system was
in freefall Bernanke worked with
Treasury under both Paulson and Geithner
to do creative and bold and original and
extraordinary measures to try to stave
off a total collapse this may have been
heroic but they were not normal monetary
policy under banan skis leadership the
Fed shoveled out literally hundreds of
billions of dollars to private financial
institutions to banks to brokerages to
insurance companies to foreign central
banks and to foreign private banks
what were the terms of those
transactions what collateral did the Fed
receive what conditions were there what
criteria was used to save some banks and
not others why did the Fed choose some
winners and choose some to be losers we
don't know the answers to those
questions in the house the House of
Representatives has passed a bill to
audit the Fed to be able to provide us
with answers for those questions Ben
Bernanke opposes that bill saying that
it represents a takeover of monetary
policy I'm sorry but with all due
respect it is disingenuous if not
dishonest to suggest that the emergency
measures that shoveled hundreds of
billions of dollars to private
institutions constitute normal monetary
policy this is a constitutional republic
it is inconceivable that we could have
the Federal Reserve without a vote of
Congress take hundreds of billions of
dollars and give it to private financial
institutions without of audit to know
the terms and conditions of those loans
and it is inconceivable that the Senate
could move to a vote of the Bernanke
nomination without first demanding and
accounting of what were extraordinary
procedures whether you think those
procedures were necessary and wise or
not if this republic is going to be
working under the laws if Congress is to
exercise its powers in control of
monetary policy then we cannot have a
private the Federal Reserve under the
Chairman's own hook essentially decide
which private institutions get hundreds
of billions of dollars in which don't
and so today we are urging the Senate
committee not to vote the nomination out
and to hold the investigation that would
we would think would be just common
sense okay op thank you any questions
yes sir
if the leadership what's are you are a
quarry hold dow jones if leadership
allows you a vote on your audit of the
Fed will you drop your hold on Bernanke
no just math action with Bloomberg who
would you rather see as chairman of the
Federal Reserve there are a number of
very fine analyst than a canvas out
there but I'm not the President of the
United States that's the president's
call he knows the same people as i do
and i look forward to another nominee
coming poet yes you said you're gonna do
everything you can but what can you do
other than get 41 but i'll hold a press
conference get the word out look what we
are trying to do in and what Bob or
Sarge is doing very well as you may know
and this happened to me more than a few
times when I was in the house is
sometimes for different reasons you have
people on the left and people on the
right coming together and there's some
very strange bedfellows coming together
in a coalition which says you know the
things that you've heard from Bob and
from bill that this appointment should
not go through so what we're trying to
do is rally the grass roots to put as
much pressure as we can on my colleagues
in the Senate to say what I think most
Americans who look at this issue it
cannot avoid the conclusion they cannot
avoid coming to Ben Bernanke failed on
his job and why would you want to
reappoint somebody to that enormously
important position with that kind of
poet track record so we're going to do
everything we can to rally the
grassroots to put pressure on members of
the Senate to vote against this
nomination talk to they make more money
needed for Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac I
would just go back to the to the point
that the bob or Asajj maiden and build
majors as well we're talking now about
trillions of dollars that have gone out
to huge private by definition financial
institutions and we don't know who
received but we don't know under what
terms that money was out lent out so i
am not sympathetic at this point to
seeing more money going out but we don't
even know who received zero interest
loans to the tune of trillions of
dollars yes ma'am hi Deena basoski
Russia today um why do you think you're
one of very few senators or members of
Congress who are pointing this out if
like you said these are these are just
the facts tell you a secret but don't
tell anybody okay Wall Street is very
powerful are quite as powerful as the
drug companies or the insurance
companies they're pretty powerful
centers are in bed with us well that's
luck this is Washington they say the
financial institutions and the insurance
companies over a ten-year period if my
memory is correct spent five billion
dollars in lobbying and campaign
contributions in order to deregulate
Wall Street the way with glass-steagall
and other laws are the protected
consumers five billion dollars over ten
years they are spending money hand over
fist right now and one has got to be
very naive not to understand the
enormous influence they have over the
political process in this country Ben
Bernanke is their guy and they want
their guy to stay in office and they are
pulling out all the stops to make sure
that that happens and defeating Wall
Street is not an easy proposition yes
sir it is it is worth noting though that
over that the house the majority of the
house voted for a bill to audit the Fed
and almost three-fourths the house
co-sponsored that bill and that we now
have six holes in the Senate and about
thirty percent of the Senate on a bill
to audit the Fed so well I think the
senator is exactly right wall street is
obviously very powerful in this terrain
the fact is people want to know what
happened and have every right to know
that's right no that's a very good point
yes sir
it comment on health care upstairs right
now they're reading room I know give me
a minute on that one how it let's let's
deal with mr. Bernanke and will do with
health gift yes this what I quickly who
are the other six holes i know god why
don't they were formerly holds we got
the senator bunning who was the senator
the managers a hold immense ahold i got
to kind of as a hold and i don't i don't
know if the sixth is in yet senator
Merkley has come out and said that he
will vote against mr. Bernanke in the
committee uh mr. Bernanke will still be
approved tomorrow at the committee level
I'm really not into speculation I don't
know find out soon enough yes sir don't
look on let the deal and you walk us
through procedurally what has to be done
to hold a vote on the floor for Bernanke
if you do not remove your Hall well I
think that we're going to have to sit
down with the leadership and work out a
process uh-uh and I think at the end of
the day on some day not yet clear when
there will be a long debate on this
issue they'll need 60 votes to prevail
which is probably the main thing other
questions on Bernanke that we can go to
health care if anyone has any questions
like yes sir senator thank you Olivier
Knox with AFP I'm wondering whether
you've had the opportunity to raise your
concerns directly with President Obama
what response you've had I've been
raising a lot of concerns lately with
President Obama that actually is not one
but I should tell you that as many of
you may know a number of months ago
about six or seven of us from the Senate
byron Dorgan Jim Webb Maria Cantwell and
some others I went to the White House
and and what we said I think reflects
the feelings of many people in our
country who very much respect this
president I think that he's doing a lot
of good things in many areas but have
felt from day one that he has not been
as strong as he might have been in terms
of Wall Street so we did I did make that
concern known way back okay maybe if
there's a question or two on health care
i'm happy to try to answer that
I would simply say that the senator
Coburn is so impressed by the Medicare
for All single-payer program that he
apparently feels that all of the people
of our country I've got here every
single word for the next many many hours
about how a single-payer program will be
the only way to bring universal
comprehensive cost effective health care
to all Americans so I really do
appreciate his desire to make the
American people know this through 10 or
12 or 14 hours of a reading but I think
he may have overdone it a little bit but
you know this is nothing more than an
ongoing stalling tactic on the part of
the Republicans you know if you take a
step back and try to get away from the
beltway here for a moment this country
has a healthcare crisis it has an
economic crisis it has a financial
crisis we are in two wars and what the
Republicans are doing is saying we want
to read every word for hour after hour
or thorough we want to obstruct any
movement in the United States Senate I
think the American people do not believe
that that is what we should do at a time
when our nation have so many serious
problems I think it's pretty sad that
voting for the read managers and many I
have as you know I have been a very
strong proponent of the public option
and the reason for that is two reasons
number one there's huge the satisfaction
in this country with private insurance
companies people believe quite correctly
the function of a private insurance
companies to make as much money as
possible and that these companies will
rip them off in any way that they can I
share that concern but the second point
is that you need to build into this
legislation strong cost containment
mechanisms and I've said a million times
the only way I will know that you're
going to have real cost containment and
comprehensive universal health care is a
medicare-for-all single-payer bill but
if you don't have that and that's
certainly not going to pass if you don't
have that at least you have to provide
real competition to the private
insurance companies through a public
option if you take that away I don't
know what prevents the prior
insurance companies from continue to
raising continuing to raise their
premium rates at the kind of level and
maybe even more than they have in recent
years so I have real concerns with this
bill as it stands right now I am talking
to the White House I am talking to the
Democratic leadership trying my best to
salvage some positive things in this
bill so I'm not on board yet at this
moment I am an undecided we're working
hard to try to make this bill a better
bill I would like to support it but I'm
not there yet yes sir I'm your Amendment
your proposed amendment is there 81
which remember was it something real
single area is there a continued blows
with private insurance at the end of the
day the reason why a medicare-for-all
single-payer system is the only way that
you're going to provide comprehensive
health care to all Americans in a
cost-effective way is you eliminate the
350 to 400 billion dollars of waste
engendered by the private insurance
companies through thousands and
thousands of separate insurance programs
who's the who's gold in each and every
case is to make a profit so what you
have seen in recent years is an
explosion of health care bureaucrats who
don't deliver babies they don't treat
people with cancer their whole function
in life is administrative and it's to
make profits for the private insurance
companies what should have happened when
we began this debate on health care is
to ask a very simple question how is it
that the United States today is spending
almost twice as much as any other major
country on health care while our health
care outcomes in many respects are worse
than other countries and the answer is
obvious we are the only major country on
Earth in which the private insurance
companies play a dominant role and I
hope I don't shock anybody in this room
when I tell you the function of a
private insurance company is not to
provide health care it's the make as
much money as it can for the owners of
that company and if you don't deal with
that in my view you're never going to
get to the heart of why our system is so
wasteful is so bureaucrat
and ends up spending so much more than
any other country on Earth way in the
back that yeah man you said if I'm going
to go you want to get there you're not
there yet short of that public option
what would get you there we're working
on a number of ideas so that I can go
forward and tell the people of the state
of Vermont and people all over this
country they look yeah this is not a
perfect bill that we all know it is a
week bill in many respects but at least
there are some components in that bill
that are going to be really strong in
protecting the needs of ordinary people
so working on a number of provisions
with the White House and the leadership
on that matter of process should you go
to reconciliation route uh if I had my
druthers I think reconciliation is an
absolutely appropriate route to go I
think what people who oppose that will
tell you is that you can't have the kind
of comprehensive legislation uh that the
Senate is trying to deal with now and
that may in fact be true but there are a
heck of a lot of things that you can do
that would strengthen our health care
system in a cost-effective way there
could be a giant step forward for the
American people are so to answer your
question yeah I certainly would have
appreciated that route ok ok I guess
ma'am this experience with the health
care debate you feel like financial
reform in the Senate is going to be
productive or get to where you would
like to well you know again I'm not into
speculation but this is what I would say
everybody knows that there is a lot of
dissatisfaction in the United States
stuff right now I mean working people
are seeing record levels of unemployment
wages are going down the gap between the
very rich and everybody else's is
getting wider and people want the
Congress to stand up for the middle
class and working families and I think
that financial reform is one opportunity
that we have to say to the American
people we understand that you are
furious at having to bail out the crooks
on Wall Street who are so reckless and
so irresponsible and we are going to
finally do it so I would hope
that this is an opportunity that
Congress ceases and that they are strong
in that effort okay thank you all very
very much